Hello everyone and welcome to lecture
five of CME296.
So we're officially entering the second
half of this class.
So we did a lot of hard work during the
first half.
We derived a tractable loss to learn how
to generate images. So if you remember
the first three lectures was us looking
from different perspectives to derive
that loss.
And then something else we did which was
again
uh hard work was figuring out in which
space those images were living. So how
to represent images.
And so this second half is going to be
more practical.
And this lecture is specifically going
to be about the architectures behind the
image generation models.
So before we start, as usual, we're
going to recap what we did
the last times.
So as I mentioned
the first three lectures were around
deriving a tractable training loss to
learn how to generate images.
So what we want is to be able to
generate images like the one that is on
the slides.
And we saw that a common denominator
is us starting from those.
So we saw three perspectives. The first
one was diffusion
with DDPM.
So we saw that we were corrupting a
clean image and then we were learning
how to reconstruct it by
predicting the noise that we had to
remove.
And so we ended up with a loss that was
actually quite nice. L2 loss on the
noise.
Then in lecture two, we saw another
perspective, which was
let's figure out
the regions of high density of the data
distribution of interest.
And what we did was derive a loss that
is based on the score.
The score here is the gradient of the
logarithm of the probability
distribution.
And then the last one was lecture three,
where we actually said, "Okay, this
problem can actually be framed as a
transport problem, where we want to go
from an initial distribution, which is
the noise,
to the target one."
And here we derived the loss based on
the velocity, aka vector field, which is
again very nice, can be expressed
as an L2 regression loss.
And in between, we have this denoising
process that is
similar in these three uh paradigms, but
done differently.
And then in lecture four, we said,
"Okay,
up until that point,
we just assumed that we were able to
represent images, the XT's,
and we said, "Okay, actually let's
figure out
a good way to represent them in a way
that makes sense."
And what we said was that we wanted them
to be represented in a space that was
not too high in dimensionality.
So there's a space called like latent
space, in which we want our images to be
represented.
And we want the representations to be
meaningful.
So what does meaningful mean? It means
having some structure
to the space,
because what we want is
our model to have an easy time
learning this generation process.
And we focused on the VAE, variational
autoencoder,
which was structuring the latent space
by having some constraints
on how
the distribution was behaving over the
latent space.
So, we saw this scale divergence term in
the last, but then we said, "Okay,
actually the images
were becoming blurry."
So, then we looked at a number of
strategies to combat the blurriness. So,
we saw the adversarial loss, we saw
perceptual loss, and so on.
So, we're happy. Now, we know how to
represent those images.
And we saw also that
if we were to condition our generation
process with a condition,
we also had a method called
classifier-free guidance
that allowed us
to generate images
by emphasizing more on the prompt.
And we did that by
predicting twice
the, let's say, uh noise to remove or
velocity or score,
and
with a guidance factor, emphasize the
generation process more towards the
prompt.
So, here this can be represented on the
image.
And this is where we stopped.
And then, of course, we had the midterm.
And today, what we're going to do
is to focus
on the architecture behind the image
generation model,
which until now,
we considered as being a black box.
So, I want to give a disclaimer.
There are many different architectures.
Our goal is not going to just have a
catalog of every single one of them.
But what I hope this lecture will
provide is at least an intuition as to
why certain components are always being
reused.
So if you walk away with just
just an understanding of why things are
the way they are, then I think
you know, it's it's going to be a a good
thing for us.
So
let's first start by
what we want.
So what we want, if you remember,
diffusion, score matching, flow
matching,
they had a few things as inputs.
So first
they had XT.
The noisy image or the noisy latent that
you're trying to denoise.
You also had some indication of the
noise level.
That's given by time step T.
And you also have a condition.
Let's call it C, which
it can be
text prompt.
For instance, if you want to generate an
image of a teddy bear reading a book.
That can be your condition.
So these three elements are your inputs
that goes through
your generation model.
And as an output
you want to predict, let's say, the
velocity.
That will allow you to then
iteratively move towards your desired
predicted image.
And the goal of this whole lecture
is to focus on that generation model. So
that's the model that we're talking
about.
But before we go
into that, I just want to I a few sides
notes. So the first one is the
condition.
So, I mentioned it can be a piece of
text.
In that case,
search models are called text-to-image
models, T2I.
But, you can also have
a text and an image as input, so an
image editing problem,
in which case the model will be called a
TI2I
model, text image-to-image model.
So, here make this teddy bear dance
along with the image of the teddy bear.
And then another thing is, of course,
the output.
I mentioned there are several ways to
parameterize your generation, can either
predict the velocity or, of course,
the noise or the score. All this is
roughly the same thing.
But, just for the sake of consistency,
we're just going to say that we're going
to
predict the velocity
just because nowadays most models do
that.
So,
with that in mind,
what do we want our model to be?
So, first, we want our model
to be able to
understand the global structure of the
image that it wants to generate.
So, that's one.
But, we also want it to understand the
nuances of the local details so that it
can
also generate crisp images.
And, of course, we want a model that not
only is able to have XT and T as input,
but can also condition that based on
external signals. And so, here it can be
input text or input image.
And we want, of course, that model to be
scalable
because, of course, nowadays we're
generating images of very high
resolution
and we're also generating videos which
we have not seen for a
so far, but we can think of this as
being also applicable there.
So these are
our wish list.
And let's start with the first model
by first thinking about how humans look
at an image.
So you see this teddy bear image. So you
have an eye on the right side of the
slide.
So when you look at this image
what you're doing is focusing on a
specific part of the image
and
skimming
through that image, scanning that image.
That's what we do
as humans.
So one natural
way
of thinking about how to build
such a model is
to have
this
bias. I will call it bias and I will
justify it why I I I say that way. We
want to have our model be biased
towards looking at the image in the way
we humans look at it.
I'm going to call that bias inductive
bias.
Who has heard of inductive bias by the
way?
Yeah, few people. So
we say that a model has an inductive
bias
when
we build it in such a way that it
behaves
in some way that we think it should
behave.
So in other words here we're going to
say, "Okay, we want our model
to take some image as input
and scan it a little bit like humans do.
And that's the reason why I'm going to
introduce an operation that maybe you're
already familiar with,
which is called the convolution
operation,
which takes some inputs, let's say an
input image,
and then uses a filter
to perform convolution operation across
that input
in order to generate or in order to
produce an output.
So, just on the terminology side,
the output is usually called feature map
or activation map.
And here this convolution process
typically leads to your output
exhibiting things like
edges, corners, texture from
your inputs.
So, it's going to extract features,
visual features.
So, another thing that I will note is on
this slide, you may think
the convolution is done in a 2D manner,
but let's remember that images are
represented in height, width, but also
depth.
Cuz you have the you know, three values
that represent a pixel.
And so, the filter is also of the same
is is is as deep,
if you want to think of it that way, as
the input.
And so, the convolution is really across
the depth axis as well.
So, in particular, those filters, they
are you know, 3D. They have a dimension
of F * F * C, which is the same C as the
channel the number of channels from on
input.
And we typically have K search filters.
And the And then the number of steps by
which we move the filter
is called a stride.
So, that's also a terminology you should
have in mind.
So, based on that,
let's remember the conditions we had. We
want our image to understand global
structure, we want to preserve local
details, we want external signals, and
we want it to be scalable.
Well, with that, at least we have
seemingly a tractable way of doing this
computation. So, let's say that number
four is good.
Local details, I think that's also
something that's
is
valid here because you are able to
capture patterns within a certain um
a certain range of, let's say, pixels.
So, that's that one is also good.
But how about the global structure?
You want your output, so here, you want
your output
to
have seen
the whole input to be able to be aware
of it.
So, there is this concept of a receptive
field,
which is defined by the area
that an activation element is able to
see.
So, here, let's suppose we have an input
that has a series of convolutions.
So, what we're saying is if we take just
one element from the output,
we want to know how many elements from
the input
it has seen.
So, this is the receptive field.
So, there is some formulas there that I
don't want us to just remember, but I
just want to call out
that the area that
an element can see
is a function of
the filter dimension
and the strides.
And if you want
the output
to have seen all the input,
you can
imagine that you need a lot of
convolutions.
Cuz here uh in the slide, if you do,
let's say, just one convolution,
then the area is just,
you know, uh let's say, five.
So, you do two convolutions, actually.
But, images, they're typically
500 by 500, 1,000 by 1,000, so you need
a lot of such convolutions.
Which may not be extractable.
So, one idea that we can have
is to have
downsampling operations
that would allow us to have
a bigger receptive field early on,
so that we can have
a global understanding of the structure.
And then, we can have some upsampling
operations
to then
end up with the same dimensions as the
input.
Right?
That's just an idea I'm throwing out,
because let's remember that our model
needs to have the input X, so the noisy
image as input,
and it needs to return
something that is as the same dimension
as the input, as well.
So, you cannot just
reduce the dimension and just call it a
day. Cannot do that.
So, for that reason,
we're going to see a series of
operations
that are going to
help us in building such a model.
So here, let's see a very common down
sampling operation.
So who has heard of pooling here?
Pooling?
Great. So pooling, as you know, is you
take, let's say, a given square, and
what you do is you just down sample it
by either taking the max value or just
the average value.
So there is no learnable parameters
there.
And speaking of learnable parameters, I
may have been a bit too fast there, but
here the filters that are used for the
convolutional operation,
they of course are learnable.
And you have F * F * C
parameters per filter plus some bias
term if you assume that there is bias
* K.
Not that I want to go to formulas, but
just giving you a sense of what is
learned and what is not learned.
So pooling, you don't learn anything.
Just the pooling operation.
So this is
>> [snorts]
>> just down sampling operations, but I
mentioned we want to also be able to up
sample.
And there is an operation called
the transpose
comp convolution
that we're not going to go into too much
detail, but I just want to call out that
there is
an up sampling operation that is the
transpose convolution that
uses filters
to broadcast elements from the input
towards the output.
So just up samples it.
So given that,
I hope
it's not
coming out of the blue that's
a model that down samples the input
and then up samples it
could be a natural choice
of such a model because here
what you're doing is
during the down sampling step
you're able to have receptive fields of
your output that sees most of the input
which is the global understanding global
understanding part
and then you have the up sampling part
so the one on the right
that just
increases your output once again
back to the dimension that it was
just in order for you to have
a shape that abides by what you want
and here
you can also have direct connections
from one to the other
to just
transport some local details that you
may have
computed
so such a model is called
U-Net
well because it's shaped like a U when
you do the
the illustration
and so
I mentioned a little bit of the
intuition but we're going to go step by
step now so
the first step is the down down sampling
step
so it has a combination of convolutions
and pooling
that are able to
down sample the dimension of the feature
map
and as we saw it just allows your output
to have seen more and more of the input
and when I say that what I mean is if
you take a single pixel a single
activation value
it has seen more and more of the inputs,
a bigger area of the inputs.
So, in that sense, what I'm saying is it
is able to understand
the global structure of the inputs.
Is everyone clear on that statement?
Yeah?
Cool. So, this is similar to an encoder,
and then you have the second step, which
is
the upsampling part. So, you have
here a feature map at the very beginning
of your
of the upsampling step, which is very
small.
And what you want is to upsample that
feature map back to the dimension of the
input.
So, here you're using a mix of
transpose convolution, also called up
convolution, and convolutions.
And you can think of this more as a
decoder.
So, it just leverages
the understanding, the global structure
understanding that is compressed
in the representation
at the very bottom, which is called the
bottleneck.
And it just
gets it back to the same dimension as
the input.
But at that step, you may tell me,
"Well,
sure, you can have a global
understanding of the structure, but you
may lose the details."
And that's where
these connections come into play.
So, during the downsampling step,
what you want is to leverage the
patterns that you're computing
in the upsampling step. So, what you're
doing is you're taking at each
level
a part of the feature map,
and you're just simply copying
So, crop uh cropping and copying.
So, that just allows local details to
flow from what you have computed in the
down sampling step
to the up sampling step.
Is that part clear?
So, the question is what are you
copying? What are you cropping? So,
great question.
Um so, what you're doing here is
the feature map that you're computing in
the down sampling step,
you're just literally taking that, like
literally doing that.
And then
the feature map that is part of the up
sampling step,
you're just concatenating
those features
to the features that are in the up
sampling step.
So, in other words, in the up sampling
procedure, you may have a feature map
that you're computing that is let's say
of size uh O * O * C.
So, what you're saying here is you're
concatenating something that is also of
size O * O * C,
where maybe the O is maybe the C can be
different, but you're just concat-
concatenating the two.
So, of course, you have some variations
of how this is done, but this is what
this
uh illustration represents.
Yep.
So, the question is why are you not
looking at the down sample features?
Because we have already lost the details
already. So, if you see on the slide,
we're actually copying and cropping
the features that are before
we're at that very down sampled output.
Because as you go down, you lose more
and more details, but then you're
gaining global understanding of the
inputs. And so, that's why you want your
connections to go you know from the very
top
to the other way and so on.
Yeah.
Yeah, so the question is how we're
training this model. So, we're training
it jointly.
So, we're not going to go into details
there, but uh you let's just assume you
can
train the whole thing by just
considering it as just a model.
So, the question is can the model output
exactly what uh the input image? So,
that is not what you want.
Because so, I think you're maybe
remembering the autoencoder that we saw
last time.
So,
the goal of the autoencoder is to learn
a representation of the input
and compress it in the in a latent space
so that you can sample from the latent
space and then reconstruct it.
And the problem here is you have the
connections that come from
the thing that you're not supposed to
have.
So, you can think of this model
as taking
a noisy latent as input, but your goal
is to not reconstruct that output. It's
actually to
predict the thing that will allow you to
denoise it.
So, in that sense, there are some
similarities with an autoencoder, but
it's very different.
Yeah.
So, the question is does the output of
the model have to be equal to the
dimensions of the input? Yes.
Because so, the question is why? Well,
if you take your input latent XT,
so if you remember back in lecture
three, which is like two three weeks
ago,
we had the iterative step, which was
X Sorry, X
T plus DT is equal to XT plus
the velocity times DT.
So, if you just look at that equation,
you just see that the dimensions need to
match.
Another way to think about it is in the
diffusion with the DPM formulation.
What you want is to find the noise to
remove, and that noise needs to match
your input image.
Exactly. Exactly.
Okay. Perfect. Um I have a lot of
contents. So, we'll try to move a little
bit faster, but I try to also do some
pauses here and there to make sure we're
we're still together now.
So, you have that model, but now you may
wonder, well,
how can you add external conditions? How
can you inform your model that you're at
time step T? How can you inform your
model that you want to condition it with
respect to some condition?
Well, that's a great question.
And so, to answer that question,
you first need
to think
about how you want to represent your
time step T
and your condition C.
Well, let's start with the time step.
Here, the goal is to represent the time
step
in a D dimensional space.
And
before I tell you how we do it, I just
want you to look at your watch.
Well, as humans,
we construct time
as a function of different dimensions.
Hours, minutes, seconds, days,
and so on and so forth.
And you can think of each of these
dimensions
as being part of a vector, if you think
about it.
And one thing that's quite interesting
about these dimensions
is that they run at different
frequencies.
So, for instance, an hour is kind of
slow to pass. So, I hope, by the way,
this lecture is fun, so you're not
feeling like an hour is slow, but hour
is slow, minute is faster,
seconds are even faster.
So, you have a difference in frequencies
in differences frequencies,
which hopefully motivates the fact
that
what we want
is to represent these time steps
as vectors
of quantities that are also sinusoidal,
so things that have some frequency to
it,
where some dimensions
are, let's say, slower than others.
So, is that motivating example intuitive
enough
for this to be making sense?
So, in other words, let me tell you what
that illustration represents.
If you take a single row,
then what you have
is
an illustration of the values of each
dimension.
So, what that means is, for instance, at
the very bottom,
or let's let's let's start at the very
top, let's say.
You have values that alternate between,
let's say, one and zero in this example,
and then as you move down, you see that
some dimensions, they vary
faster than others,
and this is exactly matching the
intuition I I mentioned.
So, that is for the time step.
Now, the condition.
So, I mentioned the condition can be a
piece of text.
Well, you have a number of ways to
represent that text.
We've seen some methods in the past
lecture in terms of how to represent
text and image.
But here I'll just mention just a few
categories of methods. So, there's one
where you have very very basic
predefined class.
And what you're doing is you're just
learning the vector representation of
that class.
Or you can go more granular
and divide your input text into tokens
and then have representation for each of
these tokens.
So, for both these categories of
methods, you have a bunch of such
methods, but one very common method
these days is just to
get a pre-trained LLM and just grab the
embeddings.
Which which we will not go into details
here, but
what people do nowadays.
And then for the first method,
we can simply take a ViT base model
and just take
the representation of the CLS token,
which I believe we briefly saw in the
last lecture.
All of that to say
that we have ways to represent the
condition.
Cool. So, let's suppose we have a
representation of the time step, we have
a representation of the condition.
Now, how do you
inject it
in your model?
Well, here again you have a number of
methods. There's no consensus.
One is injecting that to the feature
map.
So, here what I mean is you take your
vector T, you take your vector C.
Let's say you add them.
And then you make sure that the
dimension of your vector is, let's say,
C, the number of channels.
And then what you do is you add it to
your feature map, which if you remember
is of depth C.
So, that can be one way.
Another way is to modulate that feature.
And that part we will see that in about
20 minutes. So,
just wait for that.
And then the third one is you do some
cross-attention
uh operation there, which we're going to
see as well maybe in 40 minutes.
So, all of that to say
that there are a number of ways to
inject T and C,
and there is not like a standard way
that people do it. So, this is
just a way for me to tell you there are
several methods.
So, in terms of timeline,
we're in 2026.
So, just giving you a a sense of when
these models were published, when these
were used.
So, in 2015,
the U-Net paper came out in the context
of image segmentation for I believe
medical images.
But,
it is something that has not been widely
in use in the image generation field up
until the early 2020s.
So, for instance, you have the DDPM
paper,
which if you remember we focused on
during lecture one, that actually used
U-Nets as an architecture.
And then another thing that's quite
noteworthy is latent diffusion model,
which was a paper that introduced
or that
uh popularized the fact of
generating images in the latent space,
also used some form of the U-Nets.
And then uh we also had a U-Net that was
quite scaled
in a very big way uh in stable diffusion
XL, which was published in 2023.
So, if you look at that timeline, and if
you look if you look at my explanations,
you may think, well,
that's great. We have everything. Let's
stop here. Like, we have a we have our
model.
Well, not so fast.
Because in 2017
and in 2020,
there are papers that were landmark
papers that really revolutionized the
first transformer revolutionized the NLP
field.
And one question you may wonder is,
well,
they're performing so well there,
what about here? What about us?
And that's what the vision transformer
did in the image understanding space,
which took a backbone of the transformer
and applied it in the image
understanding case
and saw great results.
And so, now you may wonder, okay, but
can we do the same for image generation?
And that's what's we're going to see
now.
But before we do that,
I told you I I I will try to not give
you things out of the blue. I'll try to
build some intuition, and here one thing
I want to
try to tell you is
why would such a model be beneficial for
us? Because we have the global structure
understanding, we have the local details
preserving, we have everything. Why
would we need that?
Well, imagine if
you want to generate an image
of a teddy bear next to a mirror.
Well, what happens is in your image,
what you need
is for the low-level texture
to be very similar in one part of the
image and in
a very different part of that same
image.
So, the problem with the unit
is
you have convolutions
that are localized to in the
neighborhood in the vicinity of pixels.
But as
as you go further from that pixel, you
have a bunch of information that gets
mixed
in whatever you compute. So, you don't
have
uh
almost pixel-to-pixel or you know,
patches of pixel to patches of pixel
interaction.
So, you're not able to cleanly capture
or to cleanly
have an understanding of local detail in
one part of the image and local detail
in another part of the image.
And so, this is a kind of example that
the unit
may actually fail.
And so, for that reason
the transformer is actually a great
model for that because
Yeah, exactly. So, uh the transformer is
based on the concept of attention
which was initially introduced for text.
I'm going to
briefly mention it here, but
the idea for text was
you want to compute representations of
your words
as a function of all other words.
So, what you want is to have direct
links
from one word
to another word regardless of the
distance.
So, what you have is
a concept of queries
keys and values.
So, what you're wondering is
okay, if you have a query, if you have a
text,
you want to know how relevant or how
similar all the other pieces of text,
aka tokens, are.
So, you want to see how the query
relates to keys.
And then once you know how relevant they
are, so you take some operation of the
two, so let's say dot product that's
normalized in a good way.
And then you can take the associated
value.
So, that's the attention mechanism of
the self-attention mechanism that is
aimed at removing the inductive bias.
And here we can actually use that same
mechanism for images.
So, you can think
that
you take
pieces of your image
and you're doing the same thing. So, you
say, "Okay, given a given piece
given a set piece of image,
what are the other pieces of the same
image that are relevant to that one?"
So, it's the same mechanism.
So, what I told you also happens to be
very nicely represented mathematically,
so very tractable computationally with
the hardware that we have today.
So, you may have seen the formula
softmax of Q times key transpose over
some normalizing constant times V.
So, that is the self-attention operation
just in matrix form.
And on the right side of the slide, you
have just a transformer architecture as
it was initially introduced
in the context of
I believe it was translation. So, for
instance, English to French translation.
So, you had two parts.
One on the left side, which is called
the encoder, which computes
rich embeddings of your input,
and the right side is the decoder
that allows you to do translation one at
a time
by allowing each
of your output to interact the output
that you decoded so far to interact with
the whole input.
So, for images,
we're not translating anything.
We're just processing pieces of image
images. So, we're only going to borrow
the encoder part of the transformer, so
the left part.
And that's what we saw
the vision transformer did.
So, it took just the encoder part of the
transformer,
and
it took an image as an input,
and it did something very special to
that image as a pre-processing step. So,
what it did was
cut it into patches,
and then consider these patches as
tokens in the same way
it is done for words,
and then process them
again with the
self-attention mechanism allowing each
patch of image to interact with
all other ones
to just figure out
which ones are actually relevant.
So, this was the VIT.
And let me introduce you to the vision
generation equivalent,
the diffusion transformer, which was we
it was introduced in 2022,
which is also relying on the
self-attention mechanism,
and we're going to see exactly how.
But, the idea is very similar.
You take
a noisy latent as input.
And what you do is So, remember the wish
list that we had? We want to understand
global structure, we want to preserve
local details, and so on and so forth.
So, here what we're saying is we're just
allowing all patches to interact with
one another.
Does that make sense so far?
Yeah?
It's not out of the blue that I brought
up this model.
No, all good.
Perfect. So, let's go step by step
into how like into what each component
means here.
So, you have
on the illustration a patchify operation
that takes in your noised latent
and that divides it into patches. So,
you have, let's say, I * I * C
tensor that you divide into P * P * C
patches.
And those patches you just want to
consider them as
tokens.
And you end up with an input length of
I over P squared. So,
the smaller your patches,
the higher or the longer your sequence.
Which also which also matches your
understand your intuition.
So, in that sense, you can also tell
from this step
that there's a trade-off between
how granular you want to be
and how much computation you want to
compute.
So, that's for that. And then the second
step is to actually inject your
conditions. So, you know, the external
signals, the time step, and then the
input text, let's say.
So, here
what we do is we take our time step
embedding,
which as we saw can be
a series of sinusoidal
functions that you have in a vector,
and then your condition that can be just
an embedding. So, I believe in the DiT
paper, they just considered the
embedding of the whole text. So, just
one vector for the whole text.
So, let's suppose you have
these two quantities.
Now, the question is how do you inject
that into your model?
So,
the paper went through different
methods,
but there was one that stood out. So,
what we're going to do is for me to just
tell you what methods they tried out,
and then focus on the one that performed
the best.
So, the first method was called adaptive
layer norm,
which consisted of
taking the external signals,
and then modulating
the tokens. So, do you remember when I
told you modulating in the U-Net? So,
that's the same modulating modulation
I'm talking about.
So, that's the first method.
The second method is to say, "Okay, you
have your external signals.
What you can do is to have an extra step
in your transformer block,
where
what you do is letting your the tokens
representing the image latents
interact
with the time step, interact with the
label embedding
via cross attention.
So, here you can think of it as you have
queries, which are your noise latents,
and you're wondering which ones of your
conditions are relevant for your
noise
patch.
And then you do, you know, a query times
key, let's say um
dot product of those, and then you
multiply by value. So, you express
your noise latent as a function of your
conditions.
So, this can be a second option, and the
third
option is to just say, "Okay.
Actually, we're going to take these
vectors,
and we're just going to concatenate that
in the input sequence.
Very easy.
Well, it turns out
that after they did all these
experiments,
they saw that
the adaptive layer norm was the most
performance.
I'm going to give you a preview of what
we're going to see in lecture seven,
which is how to quantify
how good an image is.
So, there is a metric called the Fréchet
inception distance, the FID,
which is the one that is
represented here, where the lower that
metric, the better it is.
And what you see here is when you use
adaptive layer norm,
you get the bottom curve
that allows you to get
better quality image quality compared to
the other ones
as a function of
how far you are in the training process.
So, if you saw, there's actually two
versions of the adaptive layer norm.
There is adaptive layer norm, and
there's adaptive layer norm zero.
I'm going to tell you what that zero is
about.
But, let's focus on adaptive layer norm.
So,
I could very well just give you the
formula and tell you what that it is
adaptive layer norm, but
I think it's
very convenient to just build an
intuition as to why it may make sense.
So, I'm going to
use an example for that.
So, I mentioned
each patch can be represented by a
vector.
Let's assume
that we can
interpret this vector and say that,
let's say dimension is responsible for
something and another one for something
else, which may not be true,
but for the sake of this example, let's
suppose it is true.
So, remember we're in the latent space
and you know, we can have some semantic
interpretation of the dimensions, so
there is some truth to what I'm saying.
But, let's suppose you have a vector
where let's say the 10th
dimension represents the intensity of,
let's say, the brown the color the the
brown color.
Let's say dimension 24 is, you know, how
round the shape is, dimension 59 is how
fluffy the local details are, and then
dimension 130, which is how white the
color is.
So, let's suppose you have such
dimensions.
And now,
let's suppose
you want to generate an image
with the condition
a brown fluffy teddy bear.
So, you want to generate that image.
And as you remember, generating an image
is not one shot. Typically, you do that
iteratively, where you take a noisy
latent as inputs, and then you have the
condition, you have how noisy that image
is, and you try to have something as
output that will allow you to denoise
your image.
And let's suppose that
we're at a stage where there's a lot of
noise.
So, you know, the noise can be
represented on a scale that's here where
we're going to assume is between 0 and
1, where 0 is super noisy, 1 is clean.
And let's assume that time here is 0.1,
so a lot of noise.
So,
here what you would want
is to focus on So, at that stage of the
generation,
you want to focus on surfacing the
global structure of the image.
Cuz it's still super noisy. You're just
trying to sketch what the final image
is.
So, here you want
some brownness in the image. You want
some round shapes that may represent
your teddy bear and so on. So, you want
these features to surface, right?
So, our intuition tells us that
you want these dimensions to have
a higher intensity.
In contrast to that, you don't want to
have local details just yet because
you're It's very noisy, so it's not
That's not the time. And then, you don't
want any white color because your teddy
bear is brown. It's not white.
>> [snorts]
>> Now, let's suppose
you have the same condition as input,
but now you're at the more advanced
stage in your
generation process. Now, T equal 0.9,
which corresponds to almost no noise in
your input image.
So, here you may wonder, "Okay, so now
the input is already quite figured out
in terms of global structure. Now, I
need to focus on the details."
So, you want
the let's say fluffy details to have a
higher intensity.
And you don't want the round shape to be
that intense because it's already there.
And the brown color same, it's already
there. And then white color again, you
don't want it.
So, what I just told you
is
how we would like different dimensions
of the patch embedding
to have their intensity modulated
as a function of the condition, which is
for instance the input text,
and
the noise level in which you are.
So, in that sense,
what you want
is for your patch embedding
to exhibit higher intensities in the
dimensions you care
and lower dimension
lower intensity in the dimensions you
don't care.
So, in that sense,
what I propose
is how about we modulate these tokens?
How about we modulate these vectors?
So, here
what we would do is
to take the condition, to take the time
step as input,
and to obtain
some vectors, so let's call them alpha,
gamma, and beta. So, let's assume we
obtain these vectors, they are a
function of the condition and the noise
level.
And what we want to do is to modulate
the embedding of the patch.
So, how would we do that?
Well,
you take
your vector,
you do some normalization just because
it
it's not part of the modulation
procedure, but it's just good
because it just improves your training
stability. So, let's suppose you
normalize your vector.
And you do an element-wise
multiplication
with 1 + gamma.
So, if gamma is equal to the vector
zero,
the element-wise multiplication of this
and one is completely so no up. So,
nothing changes.
But, if gamma is a vector
that tells you that, okay, given
dimension should be higher and another
dimension should be lower,
then it will scale
your X.
And by the way, one I said one, but it's
the vector one.
So, you can think of it as
vector matching the dimension of gamma
of just filled with one.
So, in that sense, we can think of gamma
as being a a scale
coefficient, a scale vector, because it
scales X.
Then, you can add beta, which is a bias,
and perform some operation,
and have
an element-wise multiplication of this
whole quantity with alpha.
And alpha will be your gate.
Because
what you do is you take your X,
you flow the same X,
and what you do is you make some
operation with the that X, you scale it,
you shift it,
and you gate it with alpha.
And alpha is there to
tell you how much of that
change is going to flow in your
embedding.
So, in that sense, I'm just going to,
again, stress that these stars are
element-wise multiplications.
And
alpha, gamma, and beta have very
specific roles. So, alpha really gate
keeps this whole quantity from being
injected.
Gamma is responsible for scaling
the quantity, and then beta is there to
shift it because it's a plus
with that uh quantity.
And do you remember I told you I'm going
to say what adaptive layer norm zero is?
Do you remember in the chart?
Well,
adaptive layer norm zero
is adaptive layer norm
where when you start training,
you initialize your gates to zero such
that there is no
modification. So, by the way, you set
alpha alpha and gamma and beta to zero,
I believe, in most implementations, but
alpha being to zero
already guarantees that at the very
beginning of training,
you
Mhm?
Yeah, so uh question is unconditional?
Yes. So, at the very beginning, you
don't have any
any impact from the condition on your
embedding.
So far so good?
So, we will have a uh detailed example
after that, so I hope it will be also
clearer there, but
that is the
high-level intuition behind why adaptive
layer norm is
useful. It is there to highlight
dimensions that are important
for the task at hand. And so, here, what
we do is so, just recapping what we
said, we take our condition, so it's the
time step, it's the class label, so T
and C. We add them together and then we
use
just a multi-layer perceptron which is
just a linear projection, some
activation, and another linear
projection to obtain these gates, scale,
and shift alpha, gamma, and beta.
That are then used
used to modulate
the patch embeddings.
Uh so the question is is T corresponding
to the diffusion time step? Yes.
So it's how noisy you are in your uh
generation process. So one example is in
the very, very beginning. If let's say
your input is super noisy, then T is
going to be very close to zero. For
instance.
But you will represent that by your
vector that is uh composed of sinusoidal
functions.
Yeah, that's right. So uh the question
is is this a reverse process? Well,
actually even during training, you would
just inject the T that corresponds to
the noise level of your image.
So we're going to see exactly an example
of this. So I'll actually answer your
question in great detail in a in a
second.
Perfect. Well, with that, what I propose
is we wrap up this
and I walk you through an end-to-end
example of what that looks like.
So
your patch embeddings
you run them through your diffusion
transformer blocks.
There can be several of them.
And then the very end, you obtain
encoded tokens. So
patch embedding tokens that are aware of
one another because they went through
all these operations.
And
remember what we want is to have an
output that is of the same shape as the
input.
And so here, the step is
to reshape that output in the shape that
matters to you.
Well, the authors of DiT applied this to
the DDPM use case and they actually
assumed that they were not just
predicting the mean but also the
covariance metrics.
Uh so that's not very common by the way.
So you would more predict the mean but
not both.
Uh but I'm saying this because
that just explains why there are two
outputs.
But in our case we would just have one
output, in our case the velocity.
Should be in the same
the same shape as the inputs.
And
what the authors saw
was
that if you take the DiT architecture
and if you scale it in terms of number
of parameters
then you get better and better results.
And
they scaled it in terms of number of
parameters but they also scaled it in
terms of how granular the patches were.
Cuz the patches
they're of dimension P * P * C.
And if you take big patches then
you have a much coarser view than let's
say a
small patch, small P.
The problem with
the number of parameters is it does not
convey
that dimension. So you can have the same
number of parameters but vary P.
Which is why the authors also use
FLOPs. So who has heard of FLOPs before?
Yep. Floating point operations is just a
measure of how many operations you're
doing in your forward pass.
And that actually includes patch size
because if you remember
your input has a
length of I over P squared.
So, if you have a smaller P, you have a
bigger sequence, which is reflected in
your
flops measure.
And in particular
so, that's the pretty interesting. So,
you should not only scale one and not
the other. So, they see that if they
scale
the transformer size, they get better
results but not great.
Now, if they only scale the batch size
they get better results but not great.
But if they scale both the transformer
size and
the batch size
then they get
amazing results.
That's what you see in the figure on the
right and also the chart that tells you
uh this as a function of FID, which as I
mentioned is a metric we'll see in two
lectures, where the lower the value, the
better it is.
And that
was the DiT.
Given that the DiT is a pretty important
architecture
what we will do is take our time to go
through an end-to-end example
of exactly how that works.
So,
our goal is to take an input. So, here
uh the input text, you know, generate an
image of a teddy bear that is reading.
And what we want as an output is the
image itself.
Or the generated image, I should say.
So,
in lecture four, we saw that
we have a lot of incentive to do all of
this in the latent space because it's
more tractable computationally and it's
just easier for a model.
So, what we'll do is we'll take a look
at the latent space learned by a VAE
that is error disposal.
And you see you have two distributions.
You have on bottom left the initial
distribution, which is very easy to
sample from, and the target
distribution, which is the one that you
want to sample from.
So, what you do is you sample from your
easy distribution, typically a Gaussian
distribution in your latent space. Let's
call it Z0.
And you obtain
this thing.
Dimension I * I * C.
What you do is you take that image
and
you divide it into patches.
So, each element has a dimension of P *
P * C.
So, if you do some counting, you will
see that
it's I squared over P squared patches.
And this
is the sequence is the is the length of
your sequence.
So, you take each patch
and you want to represent them with a
vector.
So, you just perform a linear projection
and you obtain a vector of, let's say,
dimension D.
Okay, great for the patches. Now, let's
take care of the
conditions.
So, you have the timestamp embedding and
then you have the label embedding
corresponding to, let's say, the teddy
bear.
And what you do, super simple, you just
add them. Add them together
and you obtain your condition embedding.
So
far, So, here we are with our patchified
input
where each element is represented with
an embedding.
There's something I have not told you
about and is actually something that
Sherwin will cover in great detail in
hopefully 20 minutes.
When you perform these self-attention
operations,
the great thing is you let everyone
interact with everyone,
but then you lose the concept of how far
different elements are just because you
have direct links,
which is why you need to specify
in which position each input is. You
need to have a way to do that.
And here a very naive approach is to
just add some embedding that represent
the position.
This is not the norm nowadays. Shervin
will go deeper in there, but let's
assume here that we add
a position embedding to the patch
embedding.
And here we obtain a position-aware
patch embedding.
And we do the same for all the patches
in our input.
And
nowadays GPUs they love matrices, so we
just put everything in a matrix format.
So here we'll concatenate everything.
And we also have our condition embedding
vector.
Well,
let's start with that.
So I mentioned that the diffusion
transformer,
so one method of injecting the
conditions is to modulate
the patch embeddings with the
conditions.
So
a first step here is to obtain the gate,
the scale, and the shift coefficients
corresponding to that condition.
So let's do that. Here we
input this embedding through an MLP
layer, which is a projection and then
activation function to introduce
nonlinearities, and then another
projection.
And we obtain six quantities,
two for gate, two for scale, two for
shift.
So why two? Because
we will have two operations in the
diffusion transformer block. One is the
self-attention operation, the other one
is the
feed-forward neural network, and we want
these quantities
to be respectively to their own to go to
their own operation.
So,
let's go back to our position aware
patch embedding matrix.
We input that into our block. So, what
we do is we perform a layer
normalization operation,
and right after that, we use
gamma one and beta one to scale and
shift them.
We input them to the self-attention
layer,
and then
we gate
the result with alpha one,
which
we add
to the input.
So, this is becoming very complicated on
the slide, so I'm just going to
represent this operation with a
self-attention, and then alpha one,
gamma one, and beta one.
And as you remember, this is what
happens.
So, you take your input, and then you do
the attention operation with the scaled
and shifted uh input, and you gate it by
alpha one, where the star operation here
is just the element-wise
operation.
You do the same thing for the feed
feed-forward forward neural network
along with the alpha two, gamma two,
beta two coefficients.
And you obtain
an output matrix
>> [snorts]
>> that takes into consideration
all other patch embeddings. So, it's
something that went through this
self-attention computation.
So, that's why I'm
I'm saying it's contextualized. It's
because it's in the context of the other
patch embeddings.
But now, what you want is to have a
prediction that matches the input shape.
So, what you do is you perform some
normalization, some linear operation,
reshaping
in order to have
your prediction, which is the predicted
velocity
of your input Z at time T with condition
C.
In the very beginning,
Z is Z0.
T is 0.
C is well, just your class label. Just
I want an image of a teddy bear that
that is reading a book.
So, you have this. So, just recapping
exactly what I said. So, we have the
latent Z0. We have the time step T
equals 0. We have the class label. All
fed into this diffusion transformer.
And at the end of it,
we get the predicted velocity
at Z0 time T equals 0 and class label C.
And that's great.
But we're not done here.
We're only done here for the iteration
that allows us to go to
step 0 plus delta T.
And we perform So, the
formula that I wrote
is just a reference to the formula that
we derive in the flow matching case,
where you're just
numerically solving. So, here's
Euler
uh
solver that just allows you to go from
uh initial to uh target by just
following the vector field. So, that's
exactly what you're doing.
So, you obtain this Z0 plus delta T
that you can also have
represented like this on the on the left
in your latent space. So, that's great.
So, now let's do one more. Okay. You're
at time step TI.
So, you input your latent ZTI along with
the time step TI and the condition C
that is not or the class label C that is
not changing.
So, your input text.
So, put that in the diffusion
transformer. Again, you get a predicted
velocity
for that latent ZTI, for that time step
TI, and for the class label C.
And you go through the same thing. So,
you have the prediction
and you obtain ZTI plus one
by again
following the Euler method.
So, here on the left side, you have
the next step.
You continue again
and again
and again and again and again up until
Z1.
So, now you're at T equal one. You have
Z1. That's great.
Well, what do you have?
Well, no. It's not noise. It's just it's
the latent space. So, everything So,
from a human perspective, you just
cannot
you don't know what that is. That's why
it's
I represent it with the noise image, but
it is actually your final latent.
And so, the last step
is to take
the final latent Z1
and pass it through your VAE decoder
because you want to go back to the pixel
space because we humans
we understand pixels. We don't
understand the latent or at least not
yet.
And we get the pixel space image, which
is the image of your teddy bear reading
a book.
And that's great.
And you will tell me, "Actually, that's
great. We we solved it."
Well,
the truth is
these days
people are actually using a variation of
the diffusion transformer
for a number of reasons that we're going
to see now.
And
>> [snorts]
>> again, I just want to repeat one thing I
said earlier, which is
there is a number infinite number of
architectures out there, infinite number
of variations, combinations.
My hope is to just motivate
why some elements that we're going to
see are being reused actively these
days,
but they're by no mean
exhaustive.
So,
let's go back to
the example that we had with respect to
us wanting to modulate patch embeddings.
So, do you remember the example we used
where we said we want a brown, fluffy
teddy bear, and we had all these
dimensions, and we said let's say at t
equals 0.1,
we wanted brown color and round shape to
be
highlighted, but not the other ones. Do
you remember that?
So, let's suppose now I'm changing the
class label or the condition, the text
inputs
to brown fluffy teddy bear surrounded by
white walls.
So, imagine I do that.
Then,
the white color dimension, you would
want to also have it emphasized, right?
Because you have
white in your inputs.
But remember that
this modulation
is happening for all tokens
regardless of where they are.
So, in other words, what we're saying is
if you want to predict the velocity to
denoise an image
you're going to modulate
all patch embeddings in the same way.
But, here what you want is for places
where you have a teddy bear to have
brown that's increased but not the white
color.
And for places where there is the white
wall to have white increased but not
brown.
Well, you cannot do that with the DiT
and that's a big limitation.
Which is the reason why
we want to change a little bit our
approach. So, that's great, you know,
we're having the self-attention
mechanism there. It's amazing. The only
thing we want to do is to change
the way we're injecting conditions.
So,
modulating with respect to the time step
I think we can all agree that's that
makes sense cuz
all tokens of your input
they're all at the same time step. So,
it's very fair to have the same
treatment.
But,
we need to do something else when it
comes to injecting
the text input from the
from the user.
We don't want to apply the same
treatment to all tokens.
So, out there
there are two main classes of methods
that
allows us
to
introduce some nuance to the way we do
that.
And
while there is no standard
classification out there, I'm just
telling you there is two main classes of
methods that seem to emerge. One that it
involves cross attention.
And one that it involves joint
attention.
So before we go further,
I just want to explicit a little bit
more what these two correspond to.
So cross attention
is the idea of having something as
input. So your queries, your patching
bearings.
And wondering
how relevant
your keys and values, which here is your
text, is
to your queries.
So in other words,
I'm going to use a an analogy. And I
hope it's uh
something that will be intuitive to you
as well. So let's suppose you have
a painter
that paints the final image.
And then
uh let's say uh uh poet that
writes the instruction in a very elegant
way.
So it's the same thing as saying
if we were to say that the painter, the
one who determines what changes to bring
to the image,
is actually looking at a piece of text
that is brought by the writer.
And just based on that, determines what
to change on the image. So it pays
attention to the input text for a given
patch. It says, "Okay, what is
the piece of text that is relevant to
that?" And then based on that it says,
"Okay, I need to, you know, change this,
change that." So that is cross
attention.
So now, what is joint attention?
Joint attention is saying
you are considering
your image patch embeddings as input.
But you're also considering your text
embeddings as input as well.
And what you're saying is that both
these modalities
are being attended, if you want,
through the self-attention layer.
So, continuing the analogy, so let's say
I'm a I'm a sorry, I'm a painter and
let's say Shervin is a poet. So, instead
of Shervin writing to me exactly what
needs to be drawn,
now both Shervin and I are in the same
room
and we're talking about how things
should be placed with respect to the
text.
And let's suppose if I paint something
and then
I don't know, I need to write Stanford
top right and then my drawing is in such
a way that there is not that much space,
then we can talk amongst one another to
say, "Okay, actually I want Stanford to
be written in maybe smaller fonts." So,
we can change
what we are each
saying as a constraint and doing as an
image as a function of one another.
So, in other words,
cross-attention is considering text more
as being a a given.
So, it's okay.
Look at your So, you have a patch patch
embedding, look at which piece of text
is relevant for you and just do do
something.
And joint attention attention is saying,
"Okay, let's consider both
and try to see
try to
find a representation of each
such that we can get to our final
destination in the best way possible."
>> [snorts]
>> So, I hope this makes sense. All of that
to say
that nowadays most people do
joint attention related methods.
And in particular, I'm going to
introduce a term in 1 second, but before
I do that, it's exactly what I mentioned
here, joint attention. We're considering
the patch embeddings and the text
embeddings all jointly.
That goes through this attention layer
and so on.
And
the name of such an architecture
was coined as being an MMDIT. So, I
don't exactly know how you would
pronounce it, but I just go by MMDIT.
So, multimodal
diffusion transformer.
And this term was coined in a paper
that's actually not that long ago. So,
stable diffusion 3 that was published 2
years ago, so in 2024.
And this relies
on a joint attention of different
modalities.
Now, there is another dimension that
some
papers
play around with, which is
whether you want to consider
each modality separately
or jointly.
And in particular, you know, in the
diffusion transformer architecture, you
have, you know, this feed forward neural
network where you project, you do some
activation function, and you project
again where you learn
different ways to just represent the
same thing.
And
if you were to consider all modalities
as going through the same thing,
so just continuing the analogy of the
writer and the poet,
it would be as if you were saying
that both the poet and the Sorry, both
the poet and the painter,
they use the same tools.
So, you learn the same
But, if you were to consider each
modality on their own, if you were to
consider specific
projection depending on which modality
you're on, you're actually learning
tools that are tailored to the task
of whoever's doing it. So, the painter
will have great brush that is tailored
to whatever they're doing, and the poet
would have exactly
whatever is tailored to their needs.
Maybe I'm pushing it too far with this
analogy, but all of that to say that we
have two different
classes of
MMDIT. One is
single stream, so everything is treated
equally.
And the second one is double stream.
Each modality has its own stream.
And you even have papers that mixes the
two, so I call them hybrid here. So,
they contain both single stream and
double stream layers.
And the next few slides are just about
calling out
such models. So,
the state-of-the-art models that you
would see nowadays, they actually are
relying on this architecture. So, going
to just mention
a double stream MMDIT. So, this one is
Gwen image for those of you who have
heard of it.
Then you have Z image as an example of a
single stream. So, here treating
everything as
uh one.
And then uh for those of you who have
heard of it, Flux One Context
is actually doing a bit of both.
So,
I put all the links in the slides, so we
don't have time to talk about all each
of these papers, but if you're
interested, you can just go there and
just look at the papers to
to see how they design it.
It is not in the scope of the finals, so
don't worry if you do don't go there.
It's not required.
But, if you're interested, I think it's
a good good source.
And just continuing the timeline,
so
nowadays,
image generation models
are full of MMDIT based models.
And in particular, if you think about
when the diffusion transformer was
published, which was in 2022,
Stable Diffusion 3, which was
the first one to coin MMDIT, was
released in 2024. And then, the models I
mentioned were released in 2025. And
again, the ones that are being published
in 2026, they seem to follow the same
trend. All of that to say
that I think these are
relevant architectures that I think are
good to have in mind.
Okay. Looking at the time, I'm
slightly over time, but any questions on
that?
We're all good.
Perfect. So, with that, I need to give
it to Shervin.
Thank you, Evgeni.
So, with all these models,
uh we have seen that one constant is
that we need to represent the position
of the input.
So, the next section here is called
optimization.
But, we're not going to look at
optimizations of everything, just the
optimization of the position.
So, in order to make things simple,
I'm going to start in the 1D case, and
then we're going to see how we can adapt
this concept of positions in the 2D one.
So, as you recall, the original
transformer was based on text tokens.
So, in this case, where you have the
sentence a teddy bear is reading, what
you would want
is when you do comparisons between your
tokens in the attention layer
that the token teddy bear or the
representation of it
is seen as being close
uh to tokens around it or itself.
And far from others that are far from
it, right? That's the goal.
So, let's write that in mathematical
form.
So, what we want is a way
for us to compare
two embeddings.
And when you do an operation like the
dot product to have it as a function of
the distance.
But here I'm saying the dot product of
embeddings of these tokens, it's not
totally true. Here I'm going to put it
in quotes
because in the case of attention, we're
not comparing the same embeddings. We're
comparing
the query embedding with the key
embedding of the other token.
So, it's modulo some transformation.
And
just to write things down
we are going to decompose as a first
approach
the representation of the embedding of a
given token with what we call the input
embedding, which is whatever
representation we already have that is
not position specific.
And then adding it as an element-wise
addition in the vector space
the position embedding. That's what the
original transformer paper proposed.
Such that when you do the dot product
operation that I just mentioned
you have
a term that pops out
that is a dot product of these position
embeddings together.
And
I'm not saying that
all the other terms are not functions of
these position embeddings. Some of them
are cross terms, but we're just going to
to ignore them for now.
And we're going to focus on what choice
to to get for these positional
embeddings in order for the
representation to make sense.
So, the original Transformer
hardcoded it with a formula that I just
wrote down here. So, it might look
scary. Some of you might know about it
already. So, but for all the others,
might look scary.
So, you have a combination of signs and
cosines that you might ask yourself,
uh
why are they here? So, we're going to
decompose all the notations in there and
see intuitively what they are for.
So, you see that you have
the position as a numerator within these
signs and cosines. And on the
denominator, you have some huge
um number
uh put at some exponent.
And that exponent is a function of the
position in the vector.
And the dimension of the of the
embedding altogether, such that when you
vary this I between the first and the
middle position,
you cover exponents from zero to one.
So, in other words, you have these signs
that have frequencies that are either
high
when uh this I is close to zero because
you have the position over something
that is small. So, it's going to vary
quite fast. So, we're going to call them
high frequency.
And on on the other end of the spectrum,
uh when you have I close to the
dimension of the vector over two, it's
going to be close to one.
And as you can see, the number that is
elevated to that exponent
is some
number that looks arbitrary, but it's
quite large.
Um it's voluntarily taken quite large
with respect to the sequence length
because the mindset behind it
is that we want these
frequencies when I is is is high to be
considered as low.
So, in other words, when you have a
sequence length of, let's say, 500
we want these 1 over 10,000
to be so small
that the variation of that sine and
cosine is of low frequency with respect
to to the sequence length.
Does that make sense?
Okay, awesome. So, now I'm going to show
you the exact same figure that Afshin
showed in uh different context in a time
step embedding.
But, it turns out that here we choose a
similar mathematical framing, so the
same graph applies, and we're going to
analyze parts of these uh projection,
and then see how it compares with
respect to our frequencies that we
qualified as high and low.
So, on the left, we're looking
at dimensions that are early on in the
vector. So, we call them high frequency
um the high frequencies.
And as you can see, when you vary the
sequence position
these numbers, they vary between -1 and
1 quite fast.
And on the other end of the spectrum,
when you look at positions of this
vector that are uh
larger than
the cosine and sines take time in order
to cover the whole phase.
Okay, so now I talked about a given
frequency that was hardcoded.
This is a design choice. We're going to
hide it under some variable that I'm
going to call omega y.
And
and we're going to look side by side
what these vectors look like when you
take position m on one hand and position
n.
And we're going to try to see what
taking the dot product between both of
them is going to give us.
So
uh so here you see that you have these
signs that are aligned and these cosines
so that when you do the dot product
you have a sum
of these signs of similar frequencies at
position m and n.
And plus
uh product of cosines of a same
frequency at positions m and n again.
And if you recall
uh your trigonometry class sin a sin b
plus
cos a cos b
is an identity.
And you can rewrite it as a cosine of a
minus b
such that when you compute this dot
product, this is nothing else as the sum
of about
dimension of embeddings
over two terms
of this cosine of difference of terms.
So it's quite interpretable.
So now let's take a look at when we
compare positions m and n
what the dot product evolves with
respect to time.
So you see that it has these um
natural curve that overall decreases,
but it's not monotonic. It doesn't
monotonically decrease, but it but it
tends to decrease.
And you can see multiple regions
in this curve
that you can interpret as to why you
have such phenomenon happening. So, at
the very beginning
you see a sudden drop.
And this can be interpreted by the fact
that all your cosines in your sum,
whether high frequency or low frequency,
start from an angle close to zero. And
they all drop from this cosine of zero
equals one.
And then as you progress
when you increase the distance between
positions M and N
you have your high frequency
cosine terms
that oscillate between minus one and
one, and they will tend to cancel each
other out.
So, this is why you see
some oscillations, but not that much.
And then later on
you see more and more oscillations
coming in. This is your low frequency
terms that starts oscillating.
And
um this is how it can be interpreted.
So,
why are we choosing these positions
embeddings in the first place?
So, we saw that we can have an
interesting interpretation in terms of
comparing two position embeddings when
they are close versus far from each
other. You have
an intuitive interpretation as to like
the dot product that can be compared to
the distance.
Um and also something that I haven't put
here and that was highlighted by initial
authors
the
position embedding when you
increase the position by a given factor
K can be represented by a linear
operation.
So, when you have all these matrix
multiplication operations
you can see that operation as being
absorbed
by matrix computations such that
position information can be taken into
account.
So, it has this linear interpretation as
well.
And
yeah, the argument is that it's it's
very simple
because you have a precomputed formula.
So, let's say at training time you have
a given
constraint on the sequence length.
If at inference time you change that
parameter, then you're not
you're not lost because you know how to
extrapolate by the formula.
And uh yeah, so we see that it's it just
works well in practice.
But then on the flip side
uh and I'm not talking about the fact
that it's hardcoded, but more about the
absolute property of these position
embeddings.
We saw that it was introduced at the
input level
whereas
the initial motivation where I mentioned
position embeddings were helpful were
more at the attention level.
So, it seems like we're injecting this
position information at the place
where that information that doesn't
matter most.
But it might matter most at places where
you want to compare embeddings with
respect to one another. So, we're going
to see how to alleviate that.
And I mentioned as well these extra
interaction terms when you add position
embeddings at the very beginning
that might interact with the input
embeddings.
And I'm not saying this is bad, but I'm
saying this might not be the intention
we have behind these position
embeddings. So, it doesn't seem to align
with the design choice that we have in
mind.
And
just to give you um some information
regarding who used it, Basically,
everyone. Like every first paper on
transformers used absolute position
embedding. So, not necessarily the
hard-coded version, but the one that
adds it in the in the input.
So, the transformer, of course, did it
the way I presented.
The original VIT didn't hard-code it. It
was something that was learned.
And then the GIT did or hard-coded, but
in 2D space
in a manner similar to one that we're
going to see uh very soon.
But but it did so at the input level.
Yeah.
Yeah. A great one. So, yeah, what about
the 2D case? We're going to see it.
Yeah.
And uh yeah, great one.
So,
So, but but first, before doing that,
we're going to see if there is a better
location to have these position
embeddings be represented. And as you
might have guessed from all my hints,
the attention layers is going to be the
place to put them.
And this is the
um key insight from Rope, rotary
position embeddings, that was a paper in
uh 2021 that introduced it these kinds
of uh representation of positions. And
that is the leading way people do it in
practice today.
And the way it works is as follows.
You take queries,
you take keys,
and instead of feeding them in the dot
product as is, you will rotate them by a
rotation operation that takes into
account their position.
So, you take the query, you rotate it
with respect to something that depends
on M,
same for key that depends on N, its
position.
And you're going to do the dot product
of these rotated queries and keys
instead of the raw ones.
And one nice property that is
interpretable here
is that you see a rotation matrix that
depends on the difference of positions n
minus m
pop out. So, you feel like it's a design
choice that that makes sense.
Um
and then to answer
your points, now we're good for 1D, but
what about 2D? So, 2D you have these
uh coordinates,
uh but if you if you don't talk about
coordinates just yet, you might number
them in a 1D manner.
And it's not super clear whether it
makes sense at all to compare
1D numbers with respect to one another.
So, you have a few ways
to get around it. So, the first idea,
which is a similar flavor of what the
original DIT paper used,
is to segregate
axes such that you represent vectors
with respect to their coordinates in the
2D space.
And you do the x-axis
uh in some part of the vector and the
y-axis at some other parts.
And here we're talking about one given
design choice of how to
order
the indices with respect to where you
project,
but it doesn't have to be grouped by
even or odd indices. You can group these
by any way you want uh because this is
arbitrary.
And okay, so this is one way of doing
the it. It's called axial uh rope. There
is another way that you could get around
it that mitigates the fact that
uh so, here if you if you do the actual
way, one thing is that if you do the dot
product between two rotated vectors,
you realize that you're comparing x with
X and Y with Y, so you're missing that
interaction component.
And one way you can go around it is to
mix
rotations with respect to X and Y in a
same vector. So, this is the so-called
mixed
mixed rope.
And the authors of the paper that
discuss these two 2D strategies
made
um
a representation of
a given input position and applied a
frequency-based
technique that I I know some of you
might know from the physics space called
the Fourier transform. So, they applied
the Fourier transform, it's
um it's filtered out for a given
frequencies budget, only those that were
taken into consideration.
And after trying to reconstruct the
signal from this uh
from this set of frequencies, saw that
axial rope had all these actual
artifacts that were due to this lack of
interaction between the two axes,
whereas mixed rope was able to leverage
the same set of frequencies uh like the
same set of frequencies budgets
in a way more efficient way.
So, yeah, so these are two ways of
looking at them and then mixing things
seems to to make it better.
And
something else that you might worry
about beyond taking into account the 2D
case is how to make sense of these
positions when you have
different number of patches presented to
you. So, for example, let's say your
teddy bear is in low resolution versus
high resolution.
How does it make sense me as a model to
interpret what is at the center of the
image versus what is on the left or what
is on the right.
And this is what SeaDream 2
um thought about. And the idea here is
to center
the coordinates in a way that will tell
the model where the center of the image
is in order for it to locate different
parts of the image. So, instead of
having um zero like a grids that starts
from zero, you have the zero roughly
being at the center of the image, and
then you adjust the external points.
And
um one thing that you might wonder by
Afshin's
description of MM-IT models, for
example, those that perform joint
attention. So, you have these points
in the architecture where you might have
text tokens interacting with image
tokens. So, one question you might ask
yourself, how to quantify the position
of one with respect to the other?
And
by thinking about this, one thing you
might want
to think about is what wouldn't work.
So, what wouldn't work
uh intuitively is the positions at the
horizontal
lines of the of the image and the
vertical ones.
Because intuitively,
you do not want your model to think that
your text tokens are a continuation of
your image.
So, one natural position that the Queen
image paper points out is the diagonal
because it's clear that it's out of the
area of the image.
And um yeah, but by doing so, uh they
see that they can just leave together.
And if you use an actual
uh formulation of the 2D representation,
you even notice that your text tokens
become
equivalent to the 1D case because you
have your X and Ys that are incremented
by one between one another. So, just you
fall back on on the same case.
And
Um yeah, so I just went through some of
the keys that that made some of these
techniques work well.
I just want to say that this is very
much an open problem.
There is no one There is no many papers
that use the same techniques, but rather
many that use variations to reach their
own architecture goals.
And um and then there are trade-offs as
well.
And you might remember from the early
slides that we were talking about uh
teddy bear that was
wanting to dance. So, here is our teddy
bear wishing you a great weekend.